Speaker 1: Donald Trump did a rally over the
weekend in Selma, North Carolina.
He was swollen.
He was sweaty.
He was slurring out of the gate.
He looked particularly disheveled, and he
looked very confused by the teleprompter,
which of course, Obama was bad for using a
teleprompter.
But Trump uses one all the time.
Time.
The crowd was strange, and Trump seemed to
be kind of in a hurry.
He was rushing through.
Some of his teleprompter moments didn't seem
too thrilled to be there, he told incredibly
corrosive lies.
And I'm not going to play even a lot of moments
for you.
We're going to keep this short.
Just I think it's important to keep a line
on how the tone of these changes, but I'm
not going to give you 15 clips.
We'll just look at a few right here.
Trump glitching all over the place At one
point, he said that they have something on
Ping.
I don't know what that is.
Maybe you know what it is.
Listen to this,
Speaker 2: but look at this Dinesh D'Souza
movie and they have it on tape and they have
it on Ping.
They have it all over the place.
Speaker 1: It's anybody know what Ping is?
Does he mean Bing, the search engine that
like nobody uses?
Is it on Bing?
Ping, I don't even know what that means.
And the entire speech was confused like this,
it wasn't clear whether Trump was misreading
things off the prompter that he shouldn't
be using because it's bad when Obama used
the prompter as bad when Hillary used the
prompter.
It's not clear whether it was written incorrectly
on the prompter.
It's not clear if pinging means something
that you and I just don't know.
It's all very, very strange.
Another moment where Trump seemed visibly
confused by the things he was reading off
the prompter, he said that one of the January
six trials, this is almost comedic genius.
It ended in an extortion.
And if you keep listening, it seems that what
Trump means is that it ended in an exoneration.
I don't know why he called it an extortion,
but there's almost like a Freudian second
layer meaning to it.
Listen to this.
Speaker 2: And as you probably have heard,
one of the first January six trials ended
in an extortion and it was a horrible thing
what they were doing to people.
Speaker 1: But it was a horrible thing, what
they were doing to people.
But and then I think here he realizes he's
not making any sense.
Speaker 2: It was exoneration because they
effectively proved that he got waived into
the capital by the police.
Remember this, Nancy Pelosi was in charge
of the Capitol, you know that, right?
And the mayor of D.C., they were in charge
of all security, the GAO.
Speaker 1: Remember that Trump was asked send
in the National Guard to D.C..
This is a semantic game that they're talking
about, which as well the speaker of the House
generally oversees security in the Capitol.
But of course, the problems started outside
the Capitol.
They started outside the Capitol when crowd
control barriers were breached and Trump was
asked, Call in, please, please call in the
National Guard.
And he didn't do it.
So again, confused, did Trump mean to say
that it ended in an extortion instead of an
exoneration?
We don't know.
We just never know.
None of it makes any sense.
This was very interesting that Trump announced
that he is endorsing Mehmet Oz for senator
from Pennsylvania.
Now we're going to go back to this endorsement
later because MAGA World is in meltdown mode
because of this.
It's very interesting.
But check out the credentials that Trump touts
for Mehmet Oz here.
Listen to this is see if you can pick up on
it.
Speaker 2: By the way, I endorsed another
person today, Dr. Oz in Pennsylvania, Dr.
Oz.
Great guy, a good man, good man, Harvard educated.
Tremendous, tremendous career.
And they liked him for a long time.
That's like a poll, you know, when you're
on television for 18 years, that's like a
poll.
That means people like you.
But he's a did you?
Speaker 1: Did you notice what he did there?
He cites Harvard.
He goes, This is a Harvard educated doctor
as part of the reason why he's so qualified
but understand the hypocrisy.
Harvard is woke leftist indoctrination, trash
discriminating against Asian students and
ba ba ba ba ba.
Except when they want to puff up Dr. Oz or
Ted Cruz or the de Santas go to Harvard now,
I don't remember.
In that case, when their people went to Harvard,
they go Harvard.
It's fantastic.
It's the best.
It's such an implicit endorsement of these
people.
They went to Harvard, except then it's oh,
Harvard's trash.
Harvard's gone woke.
Harvard is just liberal indoctrination.
Which is it, guys.
Oh, right.
It's whichever one is convenient to you at
the time.
At another very strange moment, Donald Trump
said that he's the cleanest and most honest
human being ever created by God.
This is slightly hyperbolic.
Yeah, it's a bit of a delusion of grandeur.
Speaker 2: I've got to be the cleanest sheriff.
I think I'm the most honest human being.
Perhaps that God ever created?
Perhaps.
Instead of yeah,
Speaker 1: a very, very delusional and then
lastly, Donald Trump has been very careful
not to actually say I'm running in 2024 because
he wants to sidestep campaign finance laws.
I also am starting to think Trump may be laying
the groundwork for the health excuse for 2024.
We'll talk about that tomorrow.
I don't want to get into that today, but here
is Trump basically getting as close as he
possibly can to saying he's running without
actually saying it?
Speaker 2: Twenty twenty four.
Most importantly, we are going to take back
our beautiful, beautiful, beautiful White
House.
Yeah.
Twenty twenty four.
Speaker 1: Oh sorry, I play.
It's starting to play again there.
So there are campaign finance reasons for
which he for why he might be doing that.
But also, I am going to tell you tomorrow
about this new health thing that Trump is
introducing.
I've never heard him do it before, but he
did it in an interview with The Washington
Post late last week.
We'll talk about that tomorrow.
If you listened today and didn't see the clips
I played and you're curious, how bad are the
optics?
And they're very, very bad.
You'll be able to find all of these clips
on our Instagram at David Pakman show